[Musique]
mo
de plus
dias succès
avez vous été diagnostiqué schizophrène
il ya dix ans je veux vivre une vie
normale
c'est tout ce que je veux qu'est ce qui
est normal et qu'est ce qui n'est pas
annie pourquoi tu es là
suivent des précisions
et ça dure depuis pas mal de temps
j'ai confiance en ce traitement mais je
pense que nous pouvons tous être guéri
j'ai besoin d'être guidé c'est absurde
non je trouve pas ça débile
j'ai trouvé
ou est-ce vous qui devient croisé mon
chemin
à chaque fois que je laissais part il
trouve le moyen de se rejoindre il se
peut que ces deux là qu'une connexion
cosmique
on était juste deux êtres
qui vaille elle sur l'autre
[Musique]
oh
où